>> Laura: TIME FOR THE SECOND
INSTALLMENT OF OUR NEW SERIES
"DEFENDING THE FIRST" WHERE WE
EXPOSE THE ENEMIES OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, FREE
EXPRESSION, AND FREE THOUGHT.
RADIO TALK SHOW HOST AND DAILY
WIRE EDITOR IN CHIEF BEN SHAPIRO
HAS EMERGED AS ONE OF THE TOP
DEFENDERS OF FREE SPEECH,
PARTICULARLY ON CAMPUS.
IN A SERIES OF SPEECHES OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS, SHAPIRO HAS
DEBUNKED SACRED COWS LIKE SAFE
SPACES, MICRO-AGGRESSION, AND
THE QUEST FOR MULTICULTURALISM
AND DIVERSITY AND NOT WITHOUT
RISK TO HIS OWN PERSONAL SAFETY.
>> AND THERE IT IS, GANG.
GUESS WHAT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO STOP US.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> IF I ATTEMPT TO ENTER THAT
HALL RIGHT THERE AND SIT DOWN
JUST TO LISTEN TO SOMEBODY SPEAK
OR IF I ATTEMPT TO ASK QUESTIONS
OR ENGAGE IN FREE SPEECH, YOU
WILL HAVE ME ARRESTED.
>> Laura: THE TOLERANT ONE
JOINING US NOW, BEN SHAPIRO.
WHO WE THOUGHT OF IT IMMEDIATELY
WHEN WE LAUNCHED THIS SERIES.
YOU DON'T LOOK TOO THREATENING.
YOU'VE GOT SOME INTERESTING
IDEAS AND THOUGHT-PROVOKING
CONVERSATIONS AND YOU FREAK THEM
ALL OUT.
THEY HAVE THE HEADGEAR ON, RIOT
POLICE.
IT IS FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S SO
PATHETIC BUT IT'S ALSO VERY
DANGEROUS BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE
THE GUTS TO GO ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES I KNOW WHO ARE
INVITED TO SPEAK.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY?
I HAVE BETTER THINGS TO DO WITH
MY TIME.
ANYWAY, YOU CAN'T BLAME THEM.
BUT THAT'S IN ITSELF CHILLING
FREE SPEECH.
>> NO QUESTION.
SO MANY UNIVERSITIES SHUTTING
DOWN FREE SPEECH ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
I DON'T BLAME CONSERVATIVES WHO
DON'T WANT TO TAKE THEIR LIVES
IN THEIR HANDS.
I DON'T WANT TO PRETEND THIS IS
HAPPENING IN EVERY CAMPUS BUT
IT'S HAPPENING TO A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES.
NOT JUST CONSERVATIVES, PEOPLE